welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston this is a breakdown of House of
the Dragon episode 8. when the Phantom
of the red keep gets one vinyl nice
family dinner in
ah feels good to laugh as always let's
break down this episode shot by shot for
all the Game of Thrones nods visual
details and deeper layers of meaning you
might have missed and while I may not be
the first breakdown out there I watch it
so like the rest of you did with the
benefit of HBO's subtitles so I actually
caught every bit of dialogue that was
said in this episode in the super
amazing metaphors and deeper
implications of them this episode is
titled the lord of the tides one of the
titles of Corliss valerion whose absence
fate and succession is the Catalyst for
this episode we open in driftmark on the
back side of his Driftwood Throne which
the camera cranes over in the specific
way to make it look like it is sinking
in framed it's influence waning into the
sea and as a distance out of frame we
see Ray nice the queen Who Never Was but
her power in station Rising this episode
corliss's neck was slashed in a man bush
from the triarchy who are now in an
alliance with Dorne maester Kelvin
reports that the Ravens came in from
evenfall which is the seat of house
Tarth across shipwrecker Bay from
Storm's end rainey's clock said he is
three days away establishing some
logistics for the geography and travel
time drift Market Dragonstone are
islands that are three days by sea from
the coastal stormlands which is roughly
the same distance as King's Landing is
yet Dragon Riders can get to King's
Landing or the stormlands in less than a
day's time all is going be very
important for future characters who are
going to be racing the storms in trust
me Lehman says driftmarks should go to
him as a trueborn Valerian and he
assumes that the crown will side with
him
it's a queen rainis doesn't Flinch
because as the queen Who Never Was she
knows that we live in a society where a
queen who speaks from the throne only
has so much power on Dragonstone
construction cranes topped the
battlements showing now rhaenyra and
Damon are currently fortifying it the
camera swoops in toward this Mountaintop
which is actually a dormant volcano that
formed this island Daemon descends a
massive crack racing like Cusco and
pachado but this crack matches the
general shape of aegon the conqueror's
Valyrian steel dagger Damon being the
treacherous master of sneaks dancing
along the edge of this prophetic blade
Damon's recovering some Dragon AIDS from
a clutch left by Cyrax that's Ramirez
Dragon this clutch is a massive steamy
fleshy Mound that requires you to pick
at it presumably a sack left to protect
all three of these eggs now Rainier
previously offered one of these eggs for
aemond as part of her pitch to Alison
episode 6 but Fire and Blood tells us
that this latest clutch is the one right
before the Civil War begins produces one
egg that will go to Reina to hatch into
the dragon called morning the others
will go to Rainier and Damon's sons
aegon and viserys the Dragon Keeper's
clothes might look familiar it's because
Damon and Rainier were wearing Valyrian
robes just like this for their wedding
ceremony last episode joserius works
with maester gerardus speaking in
Valerian the history of aegon
conqueror's arrival at the Blackwater
Rush establishing that City's namesake
of King's Landing sister sailed
the great Army and landed at the
Blackwater Rush
at the end
the mouth yeah Jason's translation
leaves out the word dranyot or mouth
maybe setting up another kind of
blindness to mouths from this kid
the mouth of a dragon they're using the
famous painted table of the Targaryen
family formed by aegon the Conqueror
this is the one later used by Stannis
Baratheon and Daenerys Targaryen in Game
of Thrones meaning that this table is
gonna get moved from this Great Hall to
the higher chamber and explaining why
when we saw Damon and mazaria in that
chamber it wasn't there Chase is
determined to get the Valerian rights
ordered the tree should be
killed fell it is a related word yeah
this distinction between killed in Feld
also worth remembering for felling a
dragon from the sky is essentially
killing its writer renero worries Ray
nice Flames a chord
surely she cannot be planning to back
here no yeah rainey's flew her Dragon
mellies to King's Landing but Rainier
and Damon leave their dragons at home
and travel by sea why do they do this
well maybe they don't want to pose a
threat in their humble petition for
driftmark to go to where it was supposed
to whereas rhaenis wants to exert her
power really though I just think renira
wanted to be able to stay with her
babies and ramese was in more of a hurry
to make the trip before coralee's return
and as they arrive we hear
iron throne and her royal consort Prince
Damon Targaryen yes this is Stefan
dirkland a key Ally in the kingsguard
will play a very important role for
Rainier next episode renier is stood up
at the entrance the way she and viserys
were in episode 5 at driftmark the
greeting them is Lord Caswell this is
the Lord who congratulated her on the
stairs in episode 6 another very
important future Ally inside the red
keep throughout the castle the dragon
orgy artwork has all been taken down and
the window is now a seven-pointed star
of the faith of the seven in past
episodes we saw how Allison took down
the origi art in her own chamber while
leaving it up around the halls but now
we see she has taken it down everywhere
so that now if you notice it only
remains in viserys's chamber another
seven-pointed star looks down over the
small Council chamber matching the huge
necklace worn by Allison Lord beesberry
is still kicking around as master of
coin and his chains bear a few bees bees
beesberg discusses acceptance wanting
funds for a bronze bust to celebrate the
Festival of the mother which Allison and
cuts off proving that she's not actually
that Pious of a worshiper of Faith this
is all for show just as her prayers
before the mother's statue of Rainier's
mother's altar back in episode 2 were
also false Allison meets a kingsguard
where's everyone says I reckon you need
to wait America Grace
cargo with an e twin brother to
argill Within
George Martin Allison mixing up Eric
will also set up Eric to follow sir
darklin to support renira next episode
misspell and Eric's name and he will
never forget viserys's model of valyria
has collected dust and cobwebs incense
wafting smoke into the air looking like
the literal ruins of valyria after it
burned down viserys rots in his bed
bandages cover in his emaciated head and
neck they definitely use VFX to thin out
Paddy Constantine's body his teeth are
rotting too which actually might be a
result of the milk of the poppy that
he's been guzzling down for the pain
Patty katsidine actually confirms the
entertainment Weekly's west of Westeros
podcast that viserys is suffering from a
form of leprosy Also let's remember this
character is only 52 years old which is
really just the numbers reversed from
25. you're 25. yes can you believe it
finally old enough to rent a car Rainier
introduces her and Damon's son's aegon
and viserys named politically perhaps to
give them a stronger claim to the throne
someday should anything happen to Jace
Luke or Joffrey and probably as a dig at
Allison naming her son aegon Allison's
maid Talia brings before her a serving
girl aegon assaulted named Diana Diana
grovels at her feet and with Allison's
seven-pointed star necklace and her hair
tied in a tight bun she definitely does
come off like the statue of the mother
that we saw in the sept in episode 2
which is ironic considering what Allison
does in this scene Talia meanwhile who's
had a bigger and bigger role on this
series is played by Alexis Raven who is
married to showrunner Miguel sapochnik
Allison makes Diana drink the same plan
BT that Rainer was given at the end of
episode 4. renera and Damon worry about
viserys's care but if we should also
consult messenger audience
Yes master draw artists again is
Rainier's Dragonstone maester in the
text gerardus was reniro's pick to
succeed Grand maester Melos but Allison
denies this in favor of her own maester
Orwell is the one who gets picked as a
compromise Allison enters and notices
the scar and Rainier's arm from the
dagger cut last episode which Gerard is
stitched up you can actually see his
stitches are part of that scar tissue
and I love how Ranier instinctively
raises her arm to the womb both hiding
the scar and protecting her young in
Allison's presence Allison defends her
redecorating the emblems of the seven
seven is to guide us on an uncertain
path to remind us of a higher authority
but be assured the father is just and
commands me to forget the accusations
you have held in this room today Allison
refers to the Father the member of the
seven who represents justice but also
invokes her own literal father the hand
Otto in the yard Jason Luke watch amen
as far with sir Kristen at first Luke is
too short to see for the shoulder but
when Eamon turns around Luke suddenly
remember slashing out his eye Eamon
dodging Kristen's morning Stars
especially effective considering with
only one eye his depth of perception
would be limited and Damned as actor you
and Mitchell know how to use that one
visible eye I don't give a [ __ ] about
20s
nephews yes he says nephews before his
eye creepily shifts over to their eye
line showing how he definitely spotted
them in the crowd moments earlier during
the fight vaman marches in flanks by
guards with house Hightower sigils on
their chest plate showing his Allegiance
with the greens and when Otto invade and
Alice said meet in the small Council
chamber notice how those punch card
balls that they used to mark their
presence for official meetings are all
still in the central Bowl showing us how
this meeting is super off the books and
Shady ramese accuses Ranier of having
Lenor killed in front of the weirwood
tree this is the same location a young
Ranier had to face Allison's accusations
in episode 4 but whereas then renira
crossed in front of the tree to turn the
tables and give herself The High Ground
with the lies she told Allison here
Rainier is able to maintain the truth
that she didn't actually kill Lenor and
she merely joins rhaenice's side so that
they both face the tree together the two
women equals where near impresses
viserys on whether aegon's dream was
true because if not her burden is just
too heavy and viserys mumbles
all right
yeah viserys has definitely had far more
children at this point with Allison but
mentally he's back in time to he and
raniera's chat about aegon's dream in
episode one that is the conversation he
Loops back to at the end of the episode
and notice how a rat is scurrying on the
valyria diorama since it's been six
years it's probably not the same rad as
the one visery saw at the end of episode
six rats only live two or three years
but in fire and blood we meet assassins
named blood who's a butcher and cheese
who's a rat catcher without spoiling
much played crucial roles in this coming
civil war these rats could be setting up
the entrance of cheese a character we
might meet at the end of the season or
maybe next season viserys despite his
pain refuses milk of the poppy now on
the morning of these petitions being
called showing how it truly was this
narcotic that made him so incoherent
just think about it if you have leprosy
of 52 it doesn't mean you also have
dementia so in the throne room we start
with this overhead shot of the Iron
Throne that matches the overhead shot
that we ended on that showed the
Driftwood Throne from above together
these back-to-back chairs one faces
Eastward toward the sea one faces
Westward toward the rest of Westeros
Raymond claims that he's the closest sin
can to corliss's blood omitting Jason
Luke and renator protests but shuts it
down you have chance to make your own
petition princess renera do surveying in
the courtesy of allowing kids to be
heard you notice out to the left aegon
releases a smug grin and as vaman talks
notice there's a little moment where
Damon looks over to renera and she gives
him the subtlest nod giving him total
approval to cut off this guy's face in a
second but put yourself in my position
you're a fan of House of the Dragon you
love the dragon battles but there's only
one episode per week and it just isn't
enough if you want more dragon battles
in your life you're gonna need some help
you're gonna need Magic the Gathering
Arena Magic the Gathering Arena brings
the vast scope of the deck building card
collecting classic to your phone this
year Magic the Gathering is celebrating
its 30th anniversary and it's bigger
than ever in MTG Arena you can learn to
play collect cards challenge your
friends and build Decks that show off
your favorite fandom no matter what
you're into you'll find it at MTG Arena
which is tons of different themed planes
based on horror sci-fi fantasy and more
you can experience Dragon sorcery and
creatures throughout the planes of magic
and even enter into the world of
Dungeons and Dragons you can build
Dragon decks and have dragon pets just
like Targaryen does though are they
really pets I mean who rescued who they
right MTG arena is a great entry point
to get into or get back into magic all
you have to do is download the game on
mobile tablet or desktop to play and if
you're looking for a helping hand you
can learn to play or catch up on all
things MTG Arena using their official
YouTube channel to get started with
magic the Gathering Arena just click the
link in the description below download
MTG arena for free and begin assembling
Your Dragon deck today but vasera
surprises Everyone by showing up baymind
exchanges panicked looks with Otto and
Allison because his whole strategy of
coming to King's Landing depended on
visaira stain bedridden because last
time everyone saw each other the Sarah
threatened anyone who claimed renira's
kids where bastards would lose their
tongues we also get a close-up a bit
later of rainis taking this in this is
the moment she shifts her position to be
in favor of supporting the strong boys
viserys wears his half mask made of
Gould with the teardrop ribbon down the
cheek and curved edges altogether
evoking the molten crown for a king worn
by his descendant viserys in the Game of
Thrones era as viserys approaches the
throne on the right we see Sir Eric and
Jace are the only ones to nod their
heads at first viserys's crown falls off
his head and Damon picks it up for him
apparently this fall was purely an
accident during the take and Damon
helping him might have been improvised
by Matt Smith and now we get this great
moment where Damon literally crowns his
brother and it becomes such a symbolic
Act of respect the Rogue Prince
acknowledging his brother's Authority
and his wisdom even the wisdom to
supplant him as Heir renades decides to
side with rhaenyra and her son
supporting renira's plan to marry Jace
to Bayla and Luke to Reyna which would
settle the driftmark dispute because a
generation later valarian blood would be
back on the Driftwood Throne Allison
Otto looked gut punched because it
aligns driftmark of the whole Navy
rhaenys is dragon mellies and Bayla with
her Dragon Moon Dancer all with the
blacks and notice how in the scene
Raines and Baila previously stood closer
to the green side of the room so now
this is a major realignment vaman pissed
signs his own death sentence I will not
see it ended on the account of this
his head our children
are bastards yeah I love a good screen
from someone with nothing to lose if you
want to stop me you're gonna have to
kill me
and vaman even goes a step further
she
is
a hole hi
I love your tongue for that
he can keep his tongue yeah ah wow okay
so Damon's sword darksister is Valyrian
steel so it definitely Cuts clean though
Damon would have to have precise aim to
leave Damon's tongue intact like that to
have that quit planned but my favorite
reaction comes from Helena notice how
she grabs the side of her head as if
she's wearing hers will get removed too
aymond meanwhile Smiles at this as if to
realize good I'm not the only casualty
in the Civil War and now the ante has
been upped Otto orders Damon to be
disarmed but red armored soldiers appear
behind him facing off with the King's
Guard I don't think anyone wants to take
a blow from dark sister and since
viserys's dagger was drawn I guess it
just understood that Damon was executing
the king's order though the scene ends
with Allison to closer to the Iron
Throne then rhaenyra Orwell tells
rhaenys it is who luck to look upon the
face of death
strangers with
all times that I can come
and I'll show you your car as little as
my eyes are
up it's Western tradition for the dead
to be buried with stones on their eyes
those stones painted with open eyes so
that they can greet the stranger
remember Rainier equipped to land or
that I should have been there could be
their house words and like the two of
them rhenis is just tired of missing
things she's tired of death sneaking up
behind her back to claim her loved ones
and now she wants to face death head on
at the family feast Allison prays May
the mother smile down on this gathering
with love may the Smith mend the bonds
that have been broken for far too long
and to vaman valarian May the gods give
him rest yes siding the Smith is
interesting as the mender of broken
things but also a forger of weapons also
ironically it was a Smith who sliced off
bayman's head but Matt Smith Damon does
by breaking up the fight at the end of
the meal many things at least
temporarily viserys grosses everyone out
with his empty eye socket to appeal to
the warring sides to make peace and
Rainier and Allison seem to genuinely
toast each other aegon continues to
insult both Jace and bayilla but Jace is
able to calm himself and toast aegon and
aemond meanwhile Helena just mutters to
herself
beneath
yes more Prophecy from bug girl first we
gotta just hear out her toast I would
like to toast Baylor and Reina they'll
be married soon it isn't so bad mostly
he just ignores you except sometimes
when he's drunk yeah you notice there
was a lap in the background that totally
came from Matt Smith Damon because of
course it did but let's talk about her
prophecy here beware the Beast beneath
the boards he could refer generally to
the monster within the house the rot of
the family it could refer to the skull
of balerion the black dread beneath them
in the Dungeons and the trappings of
targaryen's false prophecy but I think
the Beast beneath the boards are the
rats scurrying beneath the boards of the
red keep and the danger they and the rat
catcher cheese will post a Helena's side
of the family though let's be honest I
think at this point even Helena doesn't
even know what it means but the dinner
seems merry at one point resiphons does
this insane golf clap that seems to
genuinely crack up Olivia Cook might be
calling back to that weird Clap That
Otto does when viserys arrives in the
hunting camp in episode three viserys
watches all this pleased but more and
more the dancing overtakes him in frame
and he leans forward in pain forcing his
exit and as his carried out timed
perfectly carried in at the same time is
this roasted pig that is placed directly
in front of Amen reminding Jace and Luke
and all of us of their pink dread prank
on aemond that's what pisses them off
right now so the insults come back out
to the health of my nephews Jace
Luke and Joffrey each of them handsome
wise
strong Jace takes offense to this I dare
you to say that again why
there's only a compliment do you not
think Yourself Strong yeah the closed
captions capitalize strong on that last
one underlining this is a deliberate
insult a fight breaks out but Damon
breaks it up wait
thing
all of you go now
yeah you can see the math in eamon's eye
is this the uncle Damon who lost to Sir
Kristen in the tourney the night I just
beat earlier or is this the uncle Damon
who just killed the guy with my name
plus a v Rainier and Allison have a warm
goodbye let me see the children home
return on Dragon back yeah she likely
will but probably not in a friendly way
we learned that Talia Allison's maid who
helped her cover up aegon's assault of
Gianna and likely several others reports
to mazaria the White Worm it's worth
remembering at the end of episode 6 when
Talia entered the room with Allison and
Lara strong Allison sent Talia out so
Allison scheming with lyrics might
remain undisturbed from her
vulnerabilities from Talia and mazaria
then on to the final scene the camera
floats into viserys's chamber over his
diorama of valyria much like we are from
the point of view of the Specter of
death The Stranger coming for the king
Allison gives viserys milk of the poppy
making him Delirious with his one eye
closed he mistakes Alison for his
earlier conversation with renera the guy
is so obsessed with the future he's
literally unstuck in time right now
the
if I believe it to be true
aegon our son his dream the song advice
and finally it is true what he saw in
the North
the prince that was promised I've been
said one
team like the realm
against the call
in the dark it is you you are the one so
this reminds us of viserys's chat with
Allison by the bonfire in episode 3 at
the hunt when he told her he was a
dreamer but wasn't so confident about it
now Allison was never told specifically
about aegon's Song of Ice and Fire like
Rainier was but now Allison's
misinterpretation of his ramblings as
referring to her and her son aegon
equips Alison with the same
self-righteousness that raniera has been
using to justify her actions it's this
Show's way of justifying both women's
decisions as coming from a futurist
sense of Duty but again as I said after
episode 1 since Jon Snow who wouldn't
become aegon the sixth he isn't the one
to kill the night King he never sits on
the Iron Throne his King all of this is
arguably based in false prophecy this
show is not about what will actually
happen it's about freaked out people who
misread the signs I Love How we get this
close-up of the Valyrian steel dagger
yeah I love that subtle sound there it
personifies this dagger with a
malevolent sentience as if it's kind of
cursed Relic that never should have made
it out of valyria and destined to Doom
any Targaryen who tries to use it
perhaps only the hands of a westerosi's
stranger is Arya did become a disciple
of the many face God can the dagger be
properly wielded mazarus reaches out his
hand and he gasps his final words
oh
sorry
yes he's envisioning Emma here it's her
face that he's caressing almost a way of
saying that for him the stranger might
take the form of his first wife really
so few characters in George R Martin's
world die of old age or of natural
causes like this so This reminds me of
the death of viserys's descendant amen
maester Eamon who gave up his titles to
join the Night's Watch and could have
become king but instead let it pass to
his brother aegon V who died tragically
at summerhall and now based off this
show an argument could be made that amen
might have also known aegon's dream on
his deathbed he called out to his baby
brother whom he had nicknamed egg and
talked about his own dream hey
[Music]
her dreams
since I was old this is one of my
favorite moments from Game of Thrones I
love it even more now if you consider
that Eamon might have also been a
Targaryen dreamer but his dream was that
he would die an old man and thus not be
the Targaryen destined to unite the
realm against the cold in the dark you
can follow me on Tick Tock Instagram and
Twitter you boss follow new Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
thank you